I broke it because I don't give up food
all right oh okay thanks
I just just won there if someone comes
up here might fall so we're gonna hold
on for a second oh you guys got little
drone cameras wait a second wait a
second so let me ask you something if we
were gonna rob a bank we had a bunch of
these racing drones you go in with you
got a team out in the parking lot
watching the parking lot we got a team
that goes into the bank the team that
goes into the bank has the guns but we
send the racing drones out to watch oh
my god we've got a controlling drones
with the camera oh my god okay Jake
Jake's controlling the drones so he's
going into all of the rooms in the bank
to make sure nobody's pulling the alarm
they go up they go up wait a second they
go up with little tiny spray cans and go
to spray out the cameras get someone
that works on the inside and route it
from the ground up that's that doesn't
sound cinematic to me your tape I've
just tape the tape yeah tape it there we
go now we could we do technically backup
this piece of tape yeah we tape the tape
down now at least two pieces of tape
have to fail for default
at least a few percent
[Music]
don't you see the tape or what
that's not fixing tape that's warning
hey most offices all you have to worry
about is if you drink the last of the
coffee or not and you have to remake a
pot in this studio you risk the fridge
door falling off every time you go to
put something in the fridge and of
course whoever opens it has the door
fall off needs to put the door back on
whose apart is it broken that's one way
to put it
just saying fool me once shame on me
fool me twice shame on you kind of the
second it's the other way around if
Bhoomi can't get fooled again so what is
this this keeps going in yeah that thing
down there also acts like a super steady
hole should we just buy a new one buy a
new one because the door falls off all
the time multiple times now you fix the
door I thought we fixed the door the
first well you guys didn't put a washer
on the back there wasn't one to begin
with however you effects for punky well
we spent all the last week working on a
fix
that being said there are like 40 VFX
shots in this video speed and progress
didn't go as well as I would have hoped
in the battlegrounds video game there's
the crate which this whole video is kind
of like wrapped around as this crate and
when it lands it starts shooting off red
smoke was I talking about the other
issue is that Nico has been gone the
entirety of last week where most of the
VFX were done and he has a lot of notes
on the shops that we've been doing he
would take a look at me like ya know he
should fix that we should change that
make that bigger all the effects are
with the exception of this shot where
the create lands
the scene which John is working on
simulating right now yeah oh I didn't
know you're gonna render it I was just
gonna write her it over here no you know
what it's fine don't worry about it yeah
go ahead and resume it's fine
I'm hoping to be done going on the
weekend the videos supposed to come out
on Tuesday the 19th coming into the day
still more work to be done so we pushes
another day to maybe Wednesday but now
we think we might put it up on Thursday
too so I was up until 4:00 a.m. last
night working on the battlegrounds video
but you know what keeps me going
that's not that one day if you aren't
subscribed that you might so please
consider hitting that subscribe button
my god I am styling what cool I just
felt like I got a haircut is that
retinol that that that's retinal imaging
so let me ask you when do you turn this
on
do you you open the front piece here
mm-hmm
then you drop a phone in here and then
you close it you drop a phone in here
yeah you put a phone in the gate open it
up open it up open it up for some reason
there you go get your flip phone in
there buddy hey I've got my flip phone
in there but I'm not seeing I have not
seen yes I am why is this not working
guys I have 365 Hawaiian shirts one for
every day I have one for every day of
the year literally I've collected them
for so long that I have Hawaiian shirts
made in Hawaii in the 1940s anyway you
guys it has been a pleasure like it
always is man yeah I got it got pushed
too far in now I can't I can't get a
little bit pull back out 3d print
something that goes
that would then stick into that no
connect 3d print in this part hopefully
I can model something fairly quickly
they're just kind of simplest thing it's
just gonna be this little sleeve that
goes in here with the built-in cylinder
coming out of it that we've read through
that okay cool
this is I think the first time I've
dabbed in my life
I don't how do you do it well you get it
you gotta learn how to dude you look
through that after all that are you
kidding me right now
so before I dab this across the room and
broke it to a fixed state I 3d printed
this a replacement this is like the
easiest thing to model in 3ds max I
literally just made a cylinder made a
really low polygon cylinder with eight
sides and then extruded another cylinder
perfectly round up through that this
should work just fine all right let's
see if this fits
[Music]
look at that no you could shave it
well it's not gonna come out is it have
you get it any won't come out I just got
a yeah I got seeing that down yeah so we
got a new package the best thing about
this package this goes to the singles
person dude like what makes this one so
special it has a 3d camera in the back
what yeah so literally like pick up
thinkin like scan things basically like
it's almost a gaming laptop in a tablet
Wow
it's insane this is what I've been
wanting for like years
it's designs from you and the best
thumbnails dude so I could use it as a
separate PC or I connect it use it just
as a Cintiq - so what you're saying is
you can make thumbnails and storyboards
on location but mine is like 2000 said
it
right now then oh yeah takes guys doing
this 45 push-up Club already do you get
harder every day
why is that it's harder today it's how
they get harder every day as you guys
know the ad pocalypse is happening right
now on YouTube things are crazy chaotic
is every man for himself except here at
corridor we have to thank you our
patrons for keeping us afloat during
this crazy ad times it's because of you
guys that were able to continue making
these videos supported directly by you
our patrons so thank you so much
there's a couple people we'd like to
give a shout to specifically on camera
here they are
Richard Linder Tristan Claire aka
corridor cheese Sean Witt Soho Clive
James Bailey Bryan and toesik I think I
pronounced it correctly sorry if I
didn't and finally Richard Blackburn you
guys have helped us out a lot
thank you so much for being our top
supporters and everybody else is
supporting us on patreon thank you so
much with your help we're bringing
happiness to thousands of people online
so thank you stickers try if you're not
our patron check out our patreon page
there's a link in the description below
we've got your cool rewards for you guys
and it helps us continue to make the
videos that you guys so enjoy thank you
didn't sound good
here we go there we go okay this is
where I need your help Carmichael this
sits bolted to the actual fridge itself
this goes inside the door and will sit
right in here like that this should be
able to go up into the hole there should
I put like a washer down I need you to
lift that door yes it's perfectly fixed
it with a 3d printed part that I modeled
in about five minutes
[Music]
[Music]